하루 종일 분명히 바빴는데
잠들기 전에 보면 막상 해낸 건 별로 없는 날
다들 있으시죠?
우리는 늘 시간이 부족하다고 말합니다
그런데 이런 궁금증이 생겼습니다
도대체 일론 머스크는 나랑 같은 24시간을 사는데
어떻게 그 많은 일을 다 처리할까?
그래서 머스크는 어떻게 시간 관리를 하는지 찾아보고
직접 따라하기 시작했습니다
처음에는 빈 다이어리에 이렇게 매일 적으면서 했는데
매일 적기 귀찮기도 하고 정말 효과가 좋아서
매일 사용할 마음으로 직접 만들어서 꾸준히 사용하고 있습니다
얼마나 효과가 좋았으면 직접 만들어서 사용할까요?
그럼 어떤 원리로 이게 실제로 도움이 되고 있는지
일론 머스크가 사용하고 있는 타임박싱에 대해
뇌각적 근거를 바탕으로 설명드리겠습니다
영상을 끝까지 보시고 따라하신다면
하루를 계획하시는데 정말 큰 도움을 받으실 수 있을 겁니다
그럼 영상 시작해 보겠습니다
이 영상은 해외에서 328만 조회수를 기록한
타임박싱 일론 머스크 타임맨이식만트 맷도우드 영상을 참고해 제작했습니다
왜 우리는 바쁜데 성과가 없을까?
우리는 보통 이렇게 시작합니다
투도 리스트를 적고 하나씩 체크하고 못하면 자책합니다
문제는 여기에 있습니다
투도 리스트에는 시간이 없습니다
전전두역은 계획과 의사 결정을 담당합니다
그런데 할 일이 10개가 적혀 있으면 뇌는 끊임없이 묻습니다
이걸 먼저 할까 저걸 먼저 할까
그 과정에서 뇌는 결정 피로를 느낍니다
콜롬비아대의 아이엔과 교수의 연구에 따르면
선택지가 많아질수록 실행 확률은 낮아진다고 밝혔습니다
즉 할 일이 많을수록 그걸 끝내지 못할 확률은 더 높아집니다
여러 회사를 운영하는 일론 머스크가 투도 리스트만 적고 움직였다면
지금처럼 여러 회사를 동시에 운영하기는 어려웠을 겁니다
그는 목록이 아니라 시간을 먼저 설계합니다
일론 머스크는 어떻게 다를까?
일론 머스크는 한때 주 100시간 가까이 일을 했고
현재도 80시간에서 90시간을 일한다고 알려져 있습니다
그는 테슬라 X, XAI, 페이스 X, 뉴럴 링크 등 여러 회사를 운영합니다
일론 머스크는 어떻게 시간을 관리할까요?
머스크는 하루 5분 단위로 쪼개서 사용합니다
이건 단순히 바쁘게 살겠다는 의미가 아닙니다
지금 이 5분 동안 무엇을 할 것인가를 명확히 정해 둔다는 의미입니다
회의도 5분 단위로 배정하고
이메일도 하루 종일 수시로 확인하기보다는
특정 시간에 몰아서 처리합니다
즉 반응 시간과 집중하는 시간을 구조적으로 분리합니다
핵심은 바로 이겁니다
그는 바쁜 사람이 아니라 시간을 핵심에 몰아놓는 사람입니다
하지만 일론 머스크의 방식 전체를 그대로 따라하려는 건
현실적으로 어렵습니다
머스크는 자기가 집중하는 동안 다른 일을 처리해줄 팀이 있고
초고속으로 집중 및 사고 전환이 가능한 환경이 있기 때문입니다
그리고 책임감과 무게감도 우리랑은 다릅니다
그래서 우리는 그의 방식의 구조를 파악해서 적용하려고 합니다
그 구조가 바로 브레인 덤프, 빅스리, 타임박싱입니다
결정 피로를 끊는 방법
머스크가 하루를 구조하는 방식의 핵심은 한 번에 하나입니다
그는 여러 회사를 운영하고 있어서 한 번에 여러 개에 집중할 것 같지만
한 시간 안에 한 문제만 붙잡습니다
이걸 우리 삶에 적용하면 첫 단계는 브레인 덤프입니다
머릿속에 있는 할 일을 전부 꺼내 적습니다
정리하지 말고 그냥 쏟아냅니다
이건 자의가느리 효과와도 연결이 되는데요
뇌는 미완성된 일은 계속 떠올리는 경향이 있습니다
미완성된 일이 많으면 많을수록 우리의 에너지를 갈감 얻습니다
그래서 종이에 적는 순간 뇌는 그 일을 계속 붙잡고 있을 필요가 없다고 판단합니다
그 다음이 빅스리입니다
머스크도 하루에 모든 걸 끝내려고 하지 않습니다
그날 가장 중요한 문제 몇 개에만 에너지를 씁니다
오늘 반드시 끝내야 하는 가장 중요한 3가지만 고릅니다
왜 3개일까요?
The four disciplines of execution에 따르면
동시에 많은 목표를 추구할수록
형과는 오히려 감소한다고 말합니다
머스크의 타임박싱 구조의 핵심은
다 하는 것이 아니라 정해진 시간에 가장 중요한 것만 하는 것입니다
시간을 먼저 정하라
그 다음 단계가 타임박싱입니다
빅스리를 언제 알지 정하는 겁니다
그렇게 하기 위해서는 먼저
내가 사용할 수 있는 시간이 얼마나 있는지 파악하는 게 중요합니다
예를 들어 투드리스트의 원고 쓰기로 끝내지 않고
새벽 5시 30분에서 7시까지 원고 작성하기
이렇게 정하면 시간이 하나의 경계가 되기 때문에
뇌는 더 이상 고민하지 않고 그 일을 바로 시작합니다
계획을 짜다 보면 이런 의문이 생깁니다
하루를 전부 계획하면 너무 답답하고
자유 시간도 없는 것 같고
오히려 시간에 쫓기면서 사는 것 같아
충분히 나올 수 있는 생각입니다
그런데 계획 없는 자유 시간은 오히려 불안감만 키웁니다
타임박싱의 핵심은 자유 시간을 없애서 목표만 쫓는 게 아니라
집중하는 시간을 명확히 만드는 겁니다
미리 계획된 자유 시간은 온전히 회복에 집중할 수 있게 합니다
여러분은 오늘 하루 몇 시간을 의도적으로 사용하셨나요
대부분은 반응하면서 하루를 보냅니다
그래서 제가 준비한 게 시몰 다이어리 입니다
하루를 시간 단위로 계획할 수 있도록 만든 도구입니다
고정 댓글에 링크를 남겨 두었어요
다운받으셔서 직접 한번 사용해 보세요
시간을 설계하는 사람과 시간에 끌려가는 사람은
지금은 차이가 나지 않는 것처럼 보이지만
이것이 쌓이면 1년 뒤에는 완전히 달라집니다
이런 주어진 시간을 전부 채울 때까지 늘어난다
하루면 끝날 일에 3일이 주어지면
그 일이 끝나는데 3일이 걸립니다
이것이 파킨슨 법칙입니다
마감이 생기면 긴장감이 생기고
그 긴장감이 집중을 도와주는 경우가 많습니다
그래서 제한된 시간을 설정하는 게 중요합니다
반대로 시간 남은 해야지
언젠간 해야지는 뇌의 입장에서는 마감이 없는 상태입니다
그래서 계속 미루게 됩니다
타임박싱은 인위적으로 마감을 만들어
집중을 끌어올리는데 도움을 줍니다
그런데 시간을 계획하다 보면 문제가 하나 있습니다
우리는 왜 시간 예측을 못 할까
이것을 계획 오류라고 합니다
사람들을 항상 최선의 상황을 기본 값으로 두고 계획을 합니다
캐나다 워털루대 연구에서
학생들에게 과제를 끝나는데 얼마나 걸렸지
최선을 다했을 경우와
평소처럼 노력했을 때의 경우를 각각 예측하게 했습니다
그런데 흥미롭게도 두 예측이 거의 차이가 나지 않았습니다
사람들은 평균을 묻더라도
실제로는 잘 풀릴 경우를 기준으로 답하는 경향이 있었습니다
그래서 우리는 계획을 세울 때
과하게 낙관적으로 계획을 세웁니다
3시간 걸릴 일을 2시간으로 계획합니다
결국 정해진 시간에 끝내지 못합니다
하지만 이건 의지가 약해서가 아니라
우리의 인지 편향 때문입니다
기록과 분해
이걸 해결하는 방법은 단순합니다
먼저 예상 시간을 적어봅니다
그리고 실제로 작업 시작 시간과
작업 종료 시간을 같이 적어봅니다
그리고 비교를 해봅니다
처음에는 내가 생각했던 것보다 더 걸릴 때가 많습니다
하지만 이 과정을 반복하다 보면
지금 내가 해야 할 할 일이 얼마나 걸릴지가 데이터로 쌓이고
뇌가 점점 시간을 예측하는데 정밀해집니다
머스크처럼 5분 단위까지는 아니더라도
30분 1시간 단위로 나눠보는 것만으로도
집중의 질이 완전히 달라집니다
또 큰 작업은 작게 쪼개세요
영상 제작 대신 썸네일 제목 제작 1시간
도입부 작성 30분
원고 작성 2시간
작업의 크기가 작을수록 예측은 정확해집니다
계획은 수정하는 것이다
아이젠 하원은 이렇게 말했습니다
계획은 중요하지만 계획 자체는 무의미하다
계획은 반드시 틀어집니다
방금 살펴본 워털루드 연구에서도 알 수 있듯이
우리는 계획을 너무 낙관적으로 작성합니다
이 사실을 알고 있고 인정해야 합니다
중요한 건 수정 능력입니다
수정할 일이 계속 생기니까
계획을 너무 빽빽하게 세우지 말고
예상치 못한 일을 처리할 시간을 미리 따로 정해 놓으세요
또 창의성이 필요한 작업은 시간을 정하기가 어렵습니다
그래서 30분에서 1시간 정도는 따로 빼놓거나
계획을 널럴하게 잡는 게 좋습니다
시간 관리는 의지 관리가 아닙니다
하루를 구조화하는 작업입니다
머스크가 특별한 의지를 가졌기 때문이 아니라
특별한 구조를 만들었기 때문입니다
브레인 덤프로 할 일을 전부 꺼내고
그것을 빅스리로 추리고
시간을 먼저 배정하고 기록하고 수정해 보세요
이 구조가 반복되면
그때부터 시간에 끌려가는 사람이 아니라
시간을 설계하는 사람이 됩니다
머스크의 삶과 우리의 삶은 규모는 다르지만
구조는 동일하게 적용할 수 있습니다
결국 차이를 만드는 건 의지가 아니라 시스템입니다
우리는 이런 말을 하죠
생각하지 않으면 사는 대로 생각한다
하루를 계획하지 않으면 세상에 끌려 다니게 됩니다
하루 10분 투자로 주도적으로
하루를 보낼 수 있다면 어떻게 하시겠어요
분명 시도를 했다가 안 하시는 분들도 계실 겁니다
계획을 짜다 보면 분명 힘든 부분도 있어요
할 일을 다 못 끝냈을 때의 자책감
계획만 자면 시간이 쫓기는 느낌
그리고 뭔가 모르게 긴장되고 답답해집니다
그런데 이건 여러분의 잘못이 아닙니다
그저 계획을 짜는데 미숙하기 때문입니다
우리가 또 힘들어지는 이유는
계획을 짱 그대로 실천하려고 해서 그래요
영상에서 말씀드린 것처럼 수정을 하면 됩니다
일주일 한 달 이렇게 하다 보면
계획이 점점 정교해집니다
그리고 하루를 계획하다 보면
나를 더 잘 알게 됩니다
아 나는 할 일이 끝나면 조금 쉬는 시간이 필요해
와 같이 나를 이해하는 과정을 겪게 되면서
할 일이 끝나면 그 뒤에 휴식을
의도적으로 넣는 등 목표를 향해
억지로 나를 밀어넣는 게 아니라
나와 같이 걸어가는 느낌을 받게 되실 겁니다
정말 살아있는 느낌으로요
우리는 정보나 지시 기술을 습득하기 위해서는
공부나 배움이라는 이름으로 훈련을 하지만
계획을 짜거나 기록을 하거나 글을 쓰는 등
내면을 훈련하는 법은 등 한시합니다
집중과 몰입은 결국 나에게서 나오는 에너지입니다
나를 이해하지 못하고 몰아붙이기만 하면
결국 오래 못 가고 쓰러집니다
귀찮고 재미없게 느껴질 수 있습니다
하지만 감정과 자극에 휘둘리지 않으려면
의식적으로 생각하고 정리하고
하루를 설계하는 연습이 필요합니다
그 과정이 바로 전두엽을 깨우는 훈련입니다
이 전두엽을 깨우는 가장 좋은 방법은
제가 정말 많은 시행착온끝에
하루 10분만 적기만 해도 변화가 일어나는
시몰 다이어리를 쓰는 것입니다
매일 포기만 하고 꾸준함이라고는 찾아볼 수 없었던
8등급이었던 제가 어떻게 바뀌었는지 궁금하시면
고정 댓글의 링크를 한번 확인해 보세요
다운받으셔서 꼭 한번 사용해 보세요
뇌 메카니즘을 바탕으로 만들었고
사용법도 뇌가학적으로 설명해 두었습니다
시몰 다이어리를 활용해
여러분의 하루를 직접 설계해 보세요
인생이 달라질 수 있습니다
이 영상이 도움이 되셨다면
다음에 또 보고 싶을 때
좋아요를 눌러주세요
구독을 누르시면
앞으로도 유익한 영상을 자주 만나보실 수 있을 겁니다
긴 영상 끝까지 시청해 주셔서 감사합니다
다음에도 유익하고
여러분 성장에 도움이 되는 영상으로 찾아뵙겠습니다